cuts to water usage are on the horizon
as
the colorado river continues continues
to shrink now southern nevada's water
czar is saying other states need to
start taking it seriously the i-team's
vanessa murphy tells us about the new
war over water
two separate water cuts are happening
first on tuesday the federal government
will announce tier two shortages on the
colorado river reducing how much water
nevada california and arizona can use
the bureau of reclamation the agency in
charge of the river says on top of that
a second group of additional cuts need
to be made between 15 and 30 percent of
the river's water use monday was the
deadline set for the seven states on the
river to make a deal but they couldn't
agree that prompted southern nevada
water authority general manager john
ensminger sending a letter to the
federal government saying the other
states aren't taking the problem
seriously he says despite the obvious
urgency of the situation the last 62
days produced exactly nothing in terms
of meaningful collective action he also
said most of the cuts need to come from
downstream of the hoover dam meaning
california since that's where most of
the water gets used this is a change in
tone the agency hasn't publicly
criticized other states for their high
water use in the past nevada has a right
to just under 2 percent of the water and
doesn't even use the full amount
california uses more than a quarter of
the water with the biggest user being
the imperial irrigation district an
agricultural center in southern
california enzinger suggests other
states do things like southern nevada is
already doing like water recycling and
turf removal programs for having a
reputation as a city of excess we're
actually one of the most water efficient
cities in the world
and that was vanessa murphy reporting
since the states could not reach a deal
to cut water before today's deadline the
federal government will now make its
move southern nevada has cut its water
use by 26 percent of the last decade
despite adding some 750 additional
thousand people